catholicism is right up there with
capitalism in killing people and making
this world a miserable miserable place
so you practicing catholicism means that
you are no longer my mother no longer
someone i look up to and you're just as
bad as the person who murdered the cow
to make that hurt
so go ahead carry your dead cow around
walk in your catholic church and listen
to them preaching bigotry and hatred and
you can just become a freaking
republican if that's what you really
want to be because you won't go to
another freaking church that's pathetic
i feel that parenting has gone wrong in
many ways man
the the people who believe that they are
just the most morally virtuous among us
tend to also be the most obnoxious among
us